quiero hacer este vídeo para aclarar
algunos términos que se han mencionado
mucho en las noticias y que tienen pues
bastante que ver con este debate con
respecto a los créditos hipotecarios en
estados unidos ya la crisis pues
inmobiliaria y todo esto y estos
términos son ahorro
ahorro
consumo
-consumo e inversión-
inversión sale entonces bueno o sea en
los libros y se plática acerca del
consumo y de la inversión pero creo que
no lo han platicado desde el punto de
vista que ahorita te voy a contar y creo
que es importante pensarlo así porque
tiene más que ver con el valor que se
añade a la sociedad bueno creo que
estamos de acuerdo en que ahorro tiene
que ver con que pues tiene cierta
cantidad de dinero que no gastaste y
pues que usted lo que das pero una vez
que ahorras después con ese dinero
tienes dos opciones puedes consumirlo o
puedes invertir lo lo que vamos a hacer
ahorita es ver pues algunos ejemplos y
pensar si corresponden a un consumo o si
corresponden a una inversión entonces
para esto vamos a suponer que tenemos un
millón de pesos vale entonces empezamos
con un millón millón de pesos y vamos a
pensar algunas opciones entonces una
primera opción digamos es no sé a lo
mejor construir una fábrica de coches le
voy a poner por aquí
fábrica fábrica de coches de coches y
esa fábrica puede ser muy buena puede
ser que haga coches no sé buenos bonitos
y baratos y yo argumento que esto de
aquí es una inversión y porque es una
inversión pues es una inversión porque
crea más valor que lo que originalmente
metimos crea más valor para la sociedad
de hecho pues nosotros al hacer esta
inversión esperamos un cierto retorno y
digo en otros vídeos he platicado acerca
de retornos y lo que sea pero ahorita
pues para decir las cosas un poco más
concretamente vamos a pensar que de este
millón de pesos que invertimos al hacer
carros logramos añadir un valor de 500
mil pesos para el dueño va de 500 mil
pesos para el dueño sea para nosotros
para el dueño
ok entonces aquí tenemos un retorno de
la mitad del 50% lo cual es un muy buen
retorno pero de hecho esta fábrica crea
más valor que estos 500 mil o sea de
hecho parte de lo que pues construye
esta fábrica aparte del valor que genera
en coches se va al consumidor y bueno
hay otra forma de pensarlo verdad si
todo este dinero si todo este valor
fuera para el dueño entonces los
consumidores pues no tenían por qué
comprar coche social o por qué por qué
pues pagarle al dueño si no están
obteniendo nada de valor entonces además
de estos 500 mil también se hace como
qué valor para el consumidor y por tanto
esto de acá es una inversión déjame
ponerle por acá que es inversión
inversión muy bien es más déjame ponerle
que todos los de inversión sea de color
verde y que todo de lo de consumo sea de
color naranja a rojo
entonces esto de acá es una inversión no
voy a marcar así
voy a poner un cuadro bueno esto de aquí
es una posibilidad para nuestro millón
de pesos otra opción no sé digamos que
somos un vagabundo para entonces yo soy
un vagabundo no tengo casa pero si tengo
este millón de pesos que ahorre no sé
con mis limosnas a través de los años y
entonces pues no tengo una casa no puedo
relajarme no tengo refugio pues no puedo
cenar tranquilo eso qué causa eso causa
que yo no pueda trabajar y por tanto que
no pueda ser productivo que no pueda
colaborar con la sociedad entonces otra
cosa que se puede hacer con este millón
de pesos es construir una casa me voy a
poner por aquí construir construir
tribu ir casa vale entonces tomo este
millón de pesos contrató un arquitecto y
le digo que me construya una casa a lo
mejor muy sencillita pero bueno ya tengo
una casa entonces qué sucede ahora ahora
ya tengo una dirección mis hijos ya
pueden jugar yo ya tengo un baño verdad
ya puedo pasar al baño ya puedo cenar
tranquilamente y entonces qué pasa ahora
en vez de pedir limosna en vez de ir por
las calles con un botecito ahora ya
puedo ir a un trabajo ya me puedo bañar
ya me puedo ver presentable y ya puedo
ser un miembro productivo de la sociedad
entonces yo argumentó que esto de aquí
también es una inversión una inversión y
en este caso el retorno que genera a lo
mejor es más difícil de medir porque
pues digo o sea si voy a ir a trabajar
entonces en parte pues lo que me pagan
de salario está diciendo que tanto
contribuyó a la sociedad pero no sé o
sea lo mejor ahorita para hacer un poco
más concreto podemos decir que qué
género pues 300 mil pesos de valor para
la sociedad al año entonces eso está
bueno porque de este millón que invertí
ahora genera 300 mil
hay más verdad más valor que se genera
porque a lo mejor no solo yo sino
también mis hijos ahora pueden
contribuir a la sociedad si no
tuviéramos una casa a lo mejor ellos
también tendrían que vender chicles en
la esquina y eso no estaría padre pero
ahora pues ya no sé con esta casa me
puedo convertir en un granjero o me
puedo convertir en un obrero de una
fábrica o incluso me puedo convertir en
un ejecutivo si el chiste es que gracias
a esta casa estoy generando 300 mil de
valor al año yo no sé digamos 100 mil
100 mil mis hijos y mi esposa y entonces
estamos contribuyendo a la sociedad una
vez más esto sería una inversión otra
vez lo pongo en su cuadrado de color
verde para indicar que es una inversión
bueno ya lo escribí aquí abajo pero
ayuda un poco más marcarlo con colores
para que sea un poco más visual en fin
ahora vámonos a una tercera que puede
ser un poco polémica pero ahorita te voy
a contar pues porque veo las cosas así
pensemos ahora que que ya no soy
vagabundo sino que ya soy una persona
con casa que tiene este millón de pesos
de acá y que usó ese millón de pesos
para las siguientes cosas para mí de la
casa
y mejoras de mi casa de mi casa vale
entonces qué tipo de mejoras puede ser
no sé a lo mejor cambio el techo y lo
convierto en un techo de granito por
decir algo de granito y pues pongo un
baño adicional en mi casa baño adicional
y no sé a lo mejor también cambio el
piso por piso laminado piso laminado de
madera de ocre así algo muy fino y muy
elegante y no sé también puede ser que
agregue otros 500 metros cuadrados a mi
casa digo a lo mejor con un millón de
pesos no alcanza para hacer esto muy
bien depende del tamaño de la casa y del
piso del tipo de piso laminado pero
pensemos que con estas mejoras ya
logramos este gastando nuestro millón de
pesos en puras mejoras de la casa
mi pregunta es esto de acá es una
inversión o es consumo pues típicamente
la gente dice invertir en mi casa le
puse piso laminado estoy haciendo una
inversión y esto se ve muchísimo en los
canales de mejoras de hogar verdad si
ves no sé este jardín y mejoras o
algunos de estos canales del canal del
hogar pues te das cuenta o bueno ahí
dicen que que esta de aquí es una
inversión porque dicen mira si inviertes
un millón de pesos en realizar estas
mejoras a lo mejor dentro de un año o
dos años va a haber una persona que te
pues que te compre tu casa no no en un
millón más sino en un millón y medio más
bueno pues yo digo que esto aunque se le
conozca típicamente como inversión no es
inversión es especulación déjame
describirlo por acá estoy aquí es
especulación
eso quedó muy feo déjame escribir un
poco más bonito
especulación la acción ya que me refiero
con esto pues a que estás como que
poniendo incertidumbre en tú en tu bueno
en tu llamada inversión estás pensando
que después va a venir a alguien y pues
va a creer que esto que valía un millón
ahora va a valer un millón y medio
entonces económicamente así realmente
hablando en términos económicos pues
vamos a ver o sea esto de aquí hace a la
gente de la casa más productiva o sea
realmente hace que sean unas mejores
personas hacen que sean más capaces de
invertir de invertir perdón de inventar
la cura contra el cáncer o pues que
inventen una forma muy buena de crear
energía barata y bonita pues no o sea la
verdad no en realidad incluso puedes
revertir esto si ahora tienes un baño
adicional tienes que gastar más tiempo
limpiando lo si tienes techo de granito
tienes que mantenerlo el piso laminado
tienes que limpiarlo con aceite es más
yo digo que estas mejoras incluso pueden
revertir el valor de la sociedad pueden
quitar el valor colectivo la riqueza
colectiva de la sociedad estas dos
opciones de acá si crean valor si crean
una mayor riqueza la sociedad en general
y parte de esa riqueza parte del retorno
de esa riqueza para la sociedad te toca
a ti en este caso son 500 mil pesos acá
es que ya tienes refugio y cosas por el
estilo pero en esta tercera opción no en
esta opción de acá pues claro sea
insisto te puede poner más feliz puede
hacer que tu hijo que tu ego mejore que
te sientas más orgulloso de tu hogar y
eso es bueno a lo mejor hace que mejore
tantito tu productividad pero en general
no aumentan al valor colectivo de la
sociedad claro le estás pagando a
trabajadores para que construyan esto y
estás colaborando en el mercado pero eso
es más como que transferencia de riqueza
no es creación de riqueza entonces más
que inversión esto de acá es una
especulación en la cual estás esperando
déjame ponerle color naranja estoy acá
finalmente el consumo entonces es una
especulación en la cual estás esperando
que alguien llegue después alguien que
pudo haber hecho exactamente lo mismo
que tú pueda comprar por por pues o sea
comprar tu casa e invertir nada más un
millón en vez de un millón y medio
entonces estás esperando que suceda eso
y en calidad no estás colaborando con el
bien de la sociedad bueno incluso sabes
que o sea yo podría hasta argumentar que
tu casa podría valer menos porque estas
mejoras de la casa lo que están haciendo
es personalizar la casa a tu gusto
entonces dentro de uno o dos años puede
ser que no consigas a nadie que le gusta
el techo de granito combinado con el
piso laminado y de hecho está pues
disminuyendo el valor de tu casa está
haciendo que se vuelva más difícil de
vender entonces bueno ya básicamente mi
idea es que estoy acá es un consumo si
es un consumo lo puse con color naranja
porque aunque se le conozca típicamente
como inversión en el fondo no es una
inversión sino que es realizar pues un
gasto de dinero para pues para poner la
casa a tu gusto a algo que a ti te gusta
con la esperanza de que en el futuro o
bueno con la especulación de que alguien
en el futuro lo valore más que tú bueno
entonces pues esa es la idea de acá este
es un primer vídeo básicamente te quería
contar esta idea una inversión es algo
como como esta fábrica o como tener una
casa a partir de no tener la que gracias
a eso se colabora
para la sociedad mientras que un consumo
simplemente es un gasto que pues sí te
puede hacer más feliz pero realmente no
colabora con el valor o con la riqueza
colectiva de la sociedad voy a seguir
con estas vídeos con estas ideas en el
próximo vídeo nos vemos hasta la próxima